a delivery driver is being hailed as a
hero chances are you've seen this video
went viral after her fearlessness and
her quick actions helped save a young
woman and her dog really incredible 8
news now reporter mary jane belliesa has
this story
stephanie lawn says she doesn't feel
like a hero lance a delivery driver with
702 logistics was on route dropping off
packages when she says she didn't think
twice about stepping in to prevent a
woman and her dog from a dog attack i
approached thinking that i was going to
save not a
and i realized that that dog was trying
to attack another dog and so i quickly
got them in my car and i got them to
their housing up and safe and that's
when the second attack happened
her bravery and courage recognized today
as county commissioners presented her
with a proclamation and medal for her
efforts
it was it was a heroic act on her part
not many people are willing to jump in
with a dog that is as aggressive as that
dog was and just put themselves in the
way we gave her the medal of honor
because we felt like this was a bit
beyond what we often see
she didn't have any duty to intervene
lance hopes her actions inspire others
to help when faced with similar
situations i definitely want to say
don't ever think yes yourself we're all
more capable than we give ourselves
credit for
anybody could have done what i did mary
jane balliesa live local now